el pasado martes 10 de mayo se radicó en
colombia el proyecto de ley
incompatible con el que busca y
legalizar las polémicas terapias de
conversión en el país también conocidas
como eco ciega la iniciativa es
impulsada por el representante a la
cámara de la alianza a ver de mauricio
toro y tiene como el fin el respeto a
las orientaciones sexuales de las
personas gay lesbianas y demás
integrantes de la comunidad lgtb y con
más el proyecto radicado ante el
parlamento colombiano fue respaldado por
una investigación del portal
periodístico volcánicas que evidencia
los exámenes cometidos en las llamadas
terapias de conversión para ello
entonces quiero saludar al protagonista
de este proyecto él es el representante
mauricio toro autor del proyecto de ley
para prohibir estas terapias
reconversión en colombia representante
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 preguntó en
qué consiste entonces este proyecto
un saludo muy especial y muchas gracias
por darnos la oportunidad de conversar
de algo tan importante para los derechos
humanos y sobre todo para la defensa de
los derechos de la población el gti en
colombia hoy hay que entender que estas
especies que son las mal llamadas
terapias de conversión son todos estos
medios que se utilizan para intentar
cambiar la orientación sexual la
identidad de género de la expresión de
una persona que hace parte de la
población lgtb y como si esto se pudiera
cambiar nosotros somos in convertibles
aquí no hay nada que curar y estas
terapias las hacen en muchos casos con
torturas físicas y psicológicas para
tratar por medio de diferentes
tratamientos pues jurados de algo que
persona enfermedad por lo tanto este
proyecto de ley contempla una serie de
medidas para castigar penalizar y
sancionar a cualquier persona así sea
del talento humano en salud o no que
quiera por medio de estas terapias y de
torturas tratar de cambiar pues la
identidad de género de expresión de
género de una persona ya sea que lo
hagan de manera voluntaria para quien va
como de manera involuntaria así que
nosotros esperamos que próximamente
podamos lograr controlar este tipo de
tera este son muy dolorosas hoy en
colombia una de cada cinco personas el
eje de tipo más afirma haber sido
sometida a algún esfuerzo sea cambiar su
orientación
mauricio la pregunta entonces en qué
consiste es en qué consiste en esta será
pieza reconversión y donde se practica
en colombia
se pueden practicar en diferentes sitios
en lugares donde van personas para
tratar adicciones como el alcoholismo la
drogadicción también se han dado casos
en iglesias cristianas en centros de
pensamiento es decir en diferentes
lugares y las practican tanto
profesionales como no profesionales de
la salud ya puede practicar psicólogos
como cualquier otro tipo de personas y
las hacen por medio de estructuras hace
unos días la fiscalía general de
colombia allanó y selló un lugar de
estos donde tenían amarradas desnudas a
dos personas que habían sido sometidas a
electrochoques habían sometido el cierre
quizás a golpes violaciones y otro tipo
de vejámenes no solamente la tortura es
psicológica sino también física en
cantidad de estos casos cuáles son los
derechos que más se vulneran en estas
prácticas mauricio
todos los derechos humanos los derechos
del gozar de la salud los derechos a la
expresión sexual a la libertad muchas de
estas personas son secuestradas son
violentadas aquí y son torturadas esto
es supremamente grave muchas personas
dicen pero esto todavía ocurre
y es impactado efectiva continúan siendo
una realidad en colombia y en muchos
lugares también cuando se espera en todo
lo que nos ha dicho que se debata este
proyecto en el congreso de la república
de colombia
nosotros esperamos que el primer debate
se pueda dar antes de la tercera semana
de este mes que avanza para que así
podamos tener la ley aprobada y pues
antes de terminar el año siguiente y
prohibir este tipo de terapias que
atentan contra los derechos humanos como
ya lo dijo human right watch la onu y
diferentes orgánicas como están las
cosas dentro del congreso es posible que
esta ley digamos prospere que se apruebe
este proyecto
siempre es difícil colombia ha sido un
congreso que en su generalidad historia
ha sido adverso a los temas que tienen
que ver con derechos lgtb más es la
corte constitucional en colombia que nos
ha ayudado a avanzar en ellos sin
embargo después de las últimas semanas
que hemos tenido hablando con diferentes
senadores y representantes a la cámara
que integran el congreso de colombia
pues han entendido la preocupación que
hay alrededor de esto y se han
solidarizado para poder garantizar así
que podamos por lo menos tener primer
debate antes de terminar el mes de junio
de este año entonces tengo la fe de que
el congreso va a respaldar pues este
proyecto porque al final pues esto
solamente es un tipo de tortura y el
progreso está comprometido pero eso no
puede ser ecológico pues ojalá eso sea
así mauricio porque como ustedes lo
estaba diciendo pues las personas son
libres de elegir su estilo de vida y qué
quieren hacer con él y no ser sometidas
a este tipo de terapias y le pregunto
por esa línea no que tanto daño le hacen
estos procedimientos de las personas que
se someten ahí el bien sea por voluntad
propia entre comillas porque la familia
lo obliga
es supremamente doloroso el daño que
hacen no sólo físico sino psicológico
destrozan a las personas y por eso
tenemos una cifra muy alarmante una de
cada tres personas que ha sido sometido
a este tipo de terapias ha intentado
suicidarse y su gravísimo porque usted
es que somos incompatibles nosotros
somos orgullosos de lo que somos no nos
pueden cambiar y nos obligan en muchos
casos son sometidos a esto a mentir y yo
quiero decir que muchas personas caen en
cautas en estos procesos yo soy el
primer congresista abiertamente gay de
colombia elegido en el congreso de la
república y tuve digamos que vivir lo
que es salir del closet sentarme con mis
familias contarle mi orientación sexual
y la angustia que viven las familias mi
madre me pregunta de los míos y esto que
es como como lo entiendo esto se puede
cambiar y yo soy un caso privilegiado
del 1% que pudo ir a un psicólogo a
tratar a su familia es decir a que mi
familia se sentara y entendiera que tú
era feliz que era mi orientación que
esto no se podía cambiar que no había
nada que curar mi madre me ayuda a salir
del closet cuando entiende que yo me
sentía orgulloso y que estaba bien serlo
y me acompaña en este proceso activista
conmigo pero es el 1% la mitad el 99% de
las personas caen en manos de pastores
de algunas iglesias o de psicólogos o de
personas que les prometen cambiar a sus
familias y él le dice nada a la persona
mire usted tiene que hacer ellis a su
familia y si usted no dice que es
heterosexual su familia va a sufrir esta
nueva web y trabajo y va a ser una
desgracia y empiezan a cambiarlo
psicológicamente a torturarlo
psiquiátricamente y las personas sin
saber empiezan a caer en este tipo de
lugares y muchas familias incluso no se
dan cuenta que en esos lugares cuando no
tengan durmiendo los torturan los
electrocutan los desnudan los golpean e
incluso los violan por eso es tan grave
y necesitamos visibilizar estos casos en
colombia podemos tener muchos centros de
tortura odio mal llamado terapia de
conversión donde personas que no saben
que están siendo sometidas a esto porque
ya han sido distorsionada a sus mentes y
al final lo que ocurre después de esto
sin duda son suicidios y exposiciones
mauricio rápidamente en 30 segunditos
antes de terminar nuestra conversación
que le diría esas familias que están
pensando llevar a sus hijos a una de
estas más llamadas terapias de
conversión
en primer lugar decirles que tienes que
apoyar a sus hijos a sus hijas a sus
hijas en este proceso para que sean las
familias las que le ayuden a uno a salir
de clase a sentirse seguro las familias
tienen que entender que somos
incompatibles que nos sentimos curiosos
que es una realidad y por eso decirle a
las familias que si quieren recurrir
acompañamiento psicológico lo hagan con
profesionales de la salud que les van a
ayudar a entender quiénes somos pero
esto no tiene un cambio y por favor no
someta a estas situaciones a sus
familiares amén los quieran los ayuden
los a ser felices ya seguir
transformando la realidad de sus países